[Music]
fight
i mean it was a good fight but
i think he broke his like orbital bone
or something because he's not
jacked up set a drop point for your team
soldier
after that second round he should have
continued going to the body
anybody need this
and drop
yeah but i mean you know it's all right
it gives us time to not be
too much in firefights get some money
and then also behind us there's a recon
right across the water
located a supply box secure that
position
let's go all right lads let's get it
done
two grand off the bat nice
oh sean i got your gun give it up
it's upstairs
it's upstairs anybody got this
how do we get upstairs here
um i think this yellow building let's
see if we can climb up this to that
nope [ __ ] this might be a bad
i don't understand why they put it
someplace you can't [ __ ] reach it
dude
objective's updating move to the next
location
did you get this yeah
well pretty sure the guys that are
hunting here probably tonight
somewhere
yeah let's get this last one careful we
don't need to all go for it
i got it you have to climb a ladder
well i assume we go across the world
i'm not going to that one that's why i'm
being hunted dude
god damn it
dude there was a recon over here we
could have gotten next and the bye
[ __ ] this bike sucks wait is there not
another buy over here
that's a bad buy dude there's one right
here in park
but it's outside of a circle
okay it's the one you marked is like
straight in the middle
this one we can kind of
yeah i know i'm trying to get to these
buy boxes
time's up get to the safe zone
where did that go
well i guess just go to this right here
if you need equipment
that's the closest it's not the perfect
place but hopefully nobody will be in
the park
yep i'm getting shot
they're on the park they're on that
[ __ ] mountain
wait
i'm driving
i'm fighting next
go go go
i just think that'd catch up to him oh
you son of a [ __ ]
[Applause]
i know i know i know i'm waiting for my
team
your teammate's done
yeah they're shooting at me right now
just keep running
oh there you go try and get him up or
get his money
hold on hold on go behind that uh go
behind that fence because
i won't live oh no no no that
i'm not done for unless you could get me
over the fence
get behind that thing right there
protection mark
move up thanks yep
i'm behind it please if you can it's not
all just behind back
sean all right i'm gonna run straight
back and straight left
oh [ __ ] i got i got hit again
john's down we got ambushed
there i'm coming peter just get let's go
to the top of this building let's get
her bye
let's find him back and go to the top of
this building
we gotta stick together so we can fight
these teams when we engage them
yeah but we people gonna stop lagging
like everybody's waiting behind for your
teammate was sent to the gulag
they'll fight for
teammate has been cleared for
redeployment
[ __ ] man there's no [ __ ] guns here
hold up drop ahead
yeah i'm going for that loadout too
[ __ ] i have to i'm going to get in i'm
going to run back to that buy
because i need to see if millie is going
to win or not
get to the new safe zone all right gas
is closing
um should probably
move into we should probably move in
this circle and then buy them there yeah
you sure
like we should go over there here yeah
you need equipment
well there's teams everybody's going to
be pushing right now because the gas is
moving in
there's a lot they're going to come up
on us and those teams are only like
there's a guy right next to us
yeah but i'm just saying let's hit this
one we'll get him we'll get him guns
there's mad guns here where'd they all
go
i bought melody back all right i'm
calling it correct
so they hit the lotus louder yeah it was
safe it was safe yeah
if you die you die just hurry i'll wait
they're at the bottom
[ __ ] you guys always do that let me
crawl down
no they were sniping they were sniping
from behind i think
not that way the other way by the by in
the circle
yeah they were up there in the circle
like that way time's up get to the safe
zone
yeah that might be on that hill straight
to your right no peek up behind you
maybe up there
so
a recon there there's a buy there
sean come into this building yeah
take the money extra cash i agree
hey i'm gonna i'm gonna put here you do
this why don't you ever just go get it
yourself
god all right it looks like it might be
clear sean right here let's go for it
you playing this other building right
here oh it's cleared
ah it's gonna be sniped well if you guys
take too long or well okay
okay we'll get a crack back
okay no craig
[Applause]
thank you
we uh just follow me just be confident
just push and circle good enough for
armor we still have to get my way back
just push with me let's go to that
recall
john i need you
all right we could get ammo in here just
be careful
assault rifle here did you hit the recon
it's not here and we're not out of here
okay sean right here that
reflex here any you need this
where's the recon
does anyone need it okay i'm going
[ __ ] it's in this building i'm going to
push it to the right you do it off to
our right in that red building
yeah i think they're in that red
building gas is closing in relocating
the safe zone
i think it's on the [ __ ] roof all
right i gotta push the roof
um three thousand fifteen hundred more
oh [ __ ] it's in the red building i don't
know if it's worth i think
maybe we should just go for circle yeah
especially and then look in front of us
someone's getting a recon right now
you can see the yellow marker yeah
yeah um
there's recon this way
i'm just putting that there there's a
whole bunch of people to the left you
see the red dots
i know all right let's move to the right
over here that's why
see where i marked i think that's a
better way to go
i didn't need that armor though we need
to try to get melody but i don't know if
that's going to happen before circle
[Applause]
one second we closest maybe just play
edge a circle in here because they're
all to the left and we're going to get
sniped
this is so bad though this is so bad
right there they're going to stop all
right
bunker down don't worry about me
i know come on come on jump just wiggle
wiggle
just run straight
train's coming that's good for us
careful these houses you want my
heartbeat sensor
i'm gonna enter this house right here
that one on heartbeat in your building
am i building
guys i'm going in here
[ __ ]
there we go um i'd like to push up that
recon
but now it's kind of too late
uh it's like right there on the edge i
don't know if it's worth
especially if there's people around we
should just hunker down
there's people
it's all good in the same building all
right
all right i'm coming i'll come
over here do you want us in this
building i'm going
up top might as well i mean i don't
think there's any other building that's
better [ __ ]
i just really wish you could
a bomb on um bottom approximately one
where the stairs are awesome just play
circle
circle can you remove your confirm for
the
for the thing for the recon i'm trying
to see where we could go after this
circle let's see
he might we might be lucky and it might
still be in circle we don't have to move
should be pushing in gas is moving
down we should start moving right now to
be honest [ __ ] it
just be aware of her behind and check in
it's mostly going to
oh right behind us behind us he's right
there contact
what it's just one guy
he's trying to buy his team back and
you're gonna rush back
oh no now i'm getting stopped from the
mountain watch out now i'm getting shot
and that's what i'm saying those guys
didn't know they were there and now i'm
out of armor
i'll drop one before we'll have some for
you and i have an armor box we'll be
fine we'll be fine
just
yeah they're right on us i know that's
why i don't want to shoot those guys
[Applause]
down
guy flying down right in front of us to
our left
here behind this rubble right here let
me drop some armor straight for you
because we're finding another team
here
hold up hold up just move try and get
the correct try get kicked try it's
quick try and get to craig
all right down the other guy his
teammate
156 boxer you just dropped armor let's
go let's go let's go let's go
yeah let's go let's go to the underneath
damn
good [ __ ] this is over here in front of
us and i'll drop the armor box for us
in front of us the guy's scoping hide
behind here
all right i'm just gonna drop it
[Applause]
nice i'm gonna try and take him out
where'd he go
he's right in front of us right there
still behind us
i killed him with my rocket launcher i'm
armor enough careful
watch her watch i'm going in this room
going into the going into the room in
the room just listen let's recover
watch me that team that we down they
might have gone revived just be careful
but i'm gonna reload yeah
yeah i think i saw him there in an armor
did you guys get everything from the
armor armor up
no we did we did we did they're up there
i see them i see them
just plain staying here just be careful
they're gonna try and push towards
[ __ ] new sights
and we're in circle let's just play this
someone's writing
i know i know why i don't have any
grenades i couldn't kill him
i can't get him where the [ __ ] are you
drop headed your way
i was stuck watch watch out the window
watch out the window behind us
john you got heartbeat yeah yeah have
your heart beat out
yeah we got one right i know i know i
know it's the guy that was sniping
[Music]
you can't shoot out there look at the
[ __ ] window
there's a team in front of us and then
there's a king behind us hold up
because when we move out from circle
they're gonna be right behind us which
i'm nervous about
and there's a guy at the by on our mini
maps we don't have a lot of so we're
just just staying here and wait
i can hear them moving they're coming
you've got gas moving in
damn i wish i had a grenade or something
to kill that guy [ __ ]
you're right yeah i know i know i know
just just chill just chill
we'll move when we absolutely have to
oh no they're still in that building
yeah sean you gotta punch your gun
look at the [ __ ] window i gotta use
the heartbeat sensor
i gotta i hear them
they might drop on us just be careful
yeah got a c4 out there good to come
because they come
is that you sean
are you why are you blowing it
there's one more there's one more
there's one more out the window out the
window to the right
25 remaining
just wait just wait just wait gas is
closing in relocating the cycles
we'll be we'll be fine we'll be fine
we'll be fine get to the corner we'll be
fine
[Applause]
didn't get [ __ ] just be careful
i need his armor i'm going for it i
could drop your armor bro
sounds so dumb right now
oh it smells too
we should just wait okay when we get out
make this guy watch her behind
anybody need this
just wait just wait i think it's two of
them just wait don't get impatient
they're gonna have to move too
i'm not i'm just looking to see what's
there
put on that building yeah we can just
wait because we i know we'll meet
we'll make circle they're shooting
someone else
[ __ ]
so if you can see on our top left you
can see that team up there there's three
we're like the last people alive there's
just four other teams left
[Applause]
good
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh that was right they just had to drop
on us
let's go baby we [ __ ] won
yeah let's [ __ ] go
let's [ __ ] go oh my god i can't
believe we [ __ ]
won oh my god
and then they didn't see me and i shot
them in the head and killed them
i said hey i'm clipping that i'm
clipping that holy [ __ ] that was amazing
clutch i [ __ ] clutch we clashed oh
man i was i had no
armor
[ __ ] yeah we were that was a rough
ending
good job dude i was nervous when i
thought they were pushing us because
they flash
being those